[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to next I'm Andy
Goodman's general manager in VP of
engineering for databases at Google
cloud and I'm excited to share with you
what's next for Builders and data
engineers
later in this session Scott Wong VP of
infrastructure at Credit Karma will join
me to talk about their Journey on Google
Cloud
today every organization on the planet
is going through some form of digital
transformation
at the heart of this always on digitally
connected World lie Mission critical
data-driven applications
powering each of these applications are
operational databases that must be
reliable resilient available performant
and safe for users
at Google Cloud our mission is to
accelerate every organization's ability
to digitally transform
and a large part of that is helping
customers innovate faster with the
unified open and intelligent data
platform
we do this by focusing on four key areas
first a unified and integrated data
Cloud for all your data
second a commitment to openness
leveraging open source and Open
Standards
third infusing Ai and ml across
data-driven workflows
and lastly empowering Builders to be
more productive and impactful
let's start with the first Focus area
creating a unified and integrated data
Cloud if you're operational and
analytical data
at Google our mission is to make
information universally accessible and
useful as evidenced by our most popular
globally available products like YouTube
Google search maps and Gmail
these products leverage a uniquely
integrated and scalable data
architecture
we've taken these learnings and brought
them into Google Cloud making it the
best place for all your data workloads
the way we've built our core services
such as Cloud spanner bigtable alloy DB
and bigquery is truly differentiated
these Services leverage Google's common
infrastructure which is unique in the
industry
our highly scalable distributed storage
system
our disaggregated compute and storage
and our high performance google-owned
Global networking allow us to provide
industry-leading tightly integrated
operational and analytical data services
today for example spanner are globally
distributed relational database service
processes over 2 billion requests per
second at Peak
it has more than six exabytes of data
under management and offers up to five
nines availability SLA which is simply
remarkable
while bigtable are highly performant
fully managed nosql database service
processes over 5 billion requests per
second at Peak and it has more than 10
exabytes of data under management and
also offers up to five nines
availability
these services offer industry-leading
availability
scale and Global reach
building on this customers need to have
easy movement of data within the data
cloud
we heard you and that's why we announced
in preview data stream for bigquery
data stream for bigquery provides easy
replication of data from operational
database sources such as lodb postgres
MySQL and Oracle directly into bigquery
this is special because we worked
closely with the bigquery team to
develop an optimized integration to
replicate database updates in real time
at very low latency
setup is just a few simple clicks
data stream for bigquery is Google's
next big step towards realizing our
vision for the unified data Cloud
combining databases analytics and
machine learning into one single
platform
but don't take my word for it let my
colleague Gabe show you how easy it is
to get started with data stream for
bigquery
creating a stream just requires a name
unique ID region source and destination
today we're capturing postgres to
bigquery
one of the great things about datastream
is it shows you the prerequisites for
your Source right in the UI so you know
what you need to prepare before starting
the streaming
connection profiles are used to define
your source and destinations they
represent the information required to
connect to an instance like the host IP
username and password we've got one
ready to go for the postgres source once
we verify we can connect in the next
step I can customize which schemas and
tables we want to bring over into
bigquery
I'll just grab two tables from our
employees schema
destination profiles similarly to the
source can be created beforehand
we can define a prefix here so it's easy
to see which data is coming from our
postgres source
summary looks good one last validation
check to be sure we haven't missed
anything
create and start and right away I can
start using the Explorer to see my data
that's come across into bigquery
wasn't that simple and there is more
to continue on this theme of easy data
replication from operational databases
for use cases like analytics event-based
architectures compliance or archival
we're announcing today in preview
bigtable change streams
this capability joins our already
existing recently launched spanner
change streams
with chain streams you can track rights
updates and delete so that they can be
replicated to Downstream systems in real
time
you will see us help make your journey
on our data Cloud simpler as we continue
to provide out-of-the-box data movement
the second Focus area is our continued
commitment to open source and Open
Standards for increased flexibility and
portability without vendor lock-in
we offer many services that are fully
compatible with the most popular open
source engines such as MySQL postgres
and redis
we help manage the complexity of running
your databases to increase your team's
agility and reduce risk
and we don't stop there we want to help
you break free from Legacy proprietary
databases with expensive and restrictive
licensing
and in the process help you modernize to
Open Standards and open apis in the
cloud
postgres an open source database has
emerged as the leading alternative to
Legacy proprietary databases because of
its Rich functionality ecosystem
extensions and Enterprise readiness
it's not surprising that millions of
users across Industries have adopted
postgres
we're focused on making Google Cloud the
best place to run your postgres
workloads
we offer you not one not two but three
fully managed services that support the
postgres interface
first Cloud SQL for postgres it is our
Enterprise ready fully managed
relational database service
you get the same experience of Open
Source postgres with the strong
manageability availability and security
capabilities of cloud SQL
and you can use the same service apis to
also manage your MySQL and SQL Server
databases it's no surprise that cloud
SQL is used by more than 90 percent of
the top 100 Google Cloud customers
second alloy DBS are fully managed
postgres compatible database service
ready for your top tier workloads and
for modernizing your legacy proprietary
databases in the cloud
in our performance tests aloe DB is more
than four times faster than open source
postgres and two times faster than
Amazon's comparable postgres compatible
service for transactional workloads
it also delivers up to 100 times faster
analytical queries than standard
postgres
and open isn't just about our technology
it's also about developing an open
ecosystem of Partners alloy DB already
integrates with many leading Technology
Solutions and has a fast-growing
ecosystem of partners with expertise
ready to support your deployments
and finally we've also added a postgres
interface for spanner our transformative
relational database with unlimited
global scale strong external consistency
and up to five nines availability
with the postgres interface for spanner
developers can take advantage of
familiar tools and skills from the
postgres ecosystem
and to further democratize access to
spanner we recently announced a free
trial to give Builders an easy way to
try out spanner at no cost
get started building with spanner today
with these capabilities we've made
Google Cloud the best home for all your
postgres workloads
and to make it easy for you to take
advantage of our open data Cloud we have
simplified our migration approach with
the right methodology tooling and
support to help accelerate your journey
take advantage of the program today
the third Focus area is around how we
are infusing Ai and ml across
data-driven workloads we use AIML across
our database Technologies to make our
services more intelligent
capabilities such as Cloud SQL cost
recommenders and alloy DB autopilot
enable dbas and devops teams to manage
performance and capacity for large
fleets of databases
in addition to infusing Ai and ml into
our databases we're providing
integration with vertex AI our Ai and ml
platform to enable model inferencing
directly within the database transaction
I'm therefore excited to announce today
in preview the integration of vertex AI
with spanner
you can now use a SQL query in spanner
to call a model and vertex AI
with this integration both alloy DB and
now spanner can simply call vertex AI
models using SQL in operational
transactions allowing data scientists to
build their models easily in vertex Ai
and developers to access these models
using the SQL query language
all these Ai and ml capabilities can
allow you to simplify management of your
databases and enable Builders to deliver
intelligent applications our final Focus
area is around empowering Builders to be
more productive with Innovative
one-of-a-kind developer experiences
industry-leading services such as Cloud
firestore are loved by developers
because of how fast one can build an
application end to end
now more than 4 million databases have
been created in firestore and firestore
applications power more than one billion
monthly active end users using Firebase
auth
we've also been pushing the envelope on
database operations with observability
features across our key services
we've introduced Cloud SQL query
insights for postgres and MySQL in
addition we make Cloud SQL cost
recommenders generally available and
introduce postgres system insights in
preview
today we're excited to announce the
preview of security and performance
recommenders for cloud SQL these
capabilities help Builders optimize
their database configurations and
improve their security posture now let's
see our ux leader cats demo of cloud SQL
insights in action
insights helps me investigate and detect
problematic queries and find the root
cause of the problem from a single pane
of glass
system insights helps me understand the
overall health of my databases I can
immediately see that the P99 of CPU
utilization is at a hundred percent
in looking at the query latency and CPU
utilization graphs I can see regular
latency spikes indicating that there are
problematic queries causing High CPU
utilization
to understand this further I can
navigate to query insights looking at
the top level query insights dashboard I
am immediately drawn to the databases
load graph it confirms that there are
several problems including one that
started around 9 15. the colors in the
graph help me see that there's an
increase in i o weight and an even
larger increase in lock weight
traditional monitoring tools only
provide a query Centric view of
performance insights provides in-context
visualization to find which application
code caused the problem
for example the tags table is especially
helpful to me as a developer since this
application was built using Django's orm
rather than by writing the SQL queries
directly
insights uses SQL commenter an open
Telemetry standard providing
instrumentation to augment SQL from
Frameworks
this first entry for the payment driver
subsidy controller and the demo send
subsidy route looks like it's the
problem
with this context I can go look at the
source code now to investigate further
I hope you enjoyed that demo and can now
see how we aim to make our database
Services easy to use to help every
Builder Focus their energy on Innovation
and differentiation we've talked through
a lot today so now let's hear from Scott
Wong VP of infrastructure at Credit
Karma to learn how they've reduced
operational burden and cost with
Google's data cloud
Scott welcome
we're glad to have you here today
thanks for having me Andy excited to be
here
tell me Scott who is Credit Karma and
why did you choose Google Cloud
in 2007 Credit Karma was founded during
the last housing crisis with a mission
to be the consumer technology platform
focused on helping our members Achieve
Financial progress and over the last 15
years we've really built this around
free credit scores providing over 4
billion credit scores to our consumers
across the U.S UK and Canada and today
nearly 130 million members use our
product but Financial progress term our
members means much more than just credit
reports we are the go-to destination for
everything related to financial goals
and to provide this we provide
personalized data-driven insights to our
members to feel more confident about
their major money decisions and at the
center of these insights is our data
models and Data Systems all being
powered by Google cloud services today
our Cloud migration Journey started
almost six years ago on the left hand
side is our infrastructure and our
traditional Data Centers before we move
to cloud and on the right hand side you
can see is our current infrastructure in
Google cloud services we started moving
to cloud with our data warehouse and
that moving to bigquery and then we
started to methodically started moving
down the stack to our whole
recommendations pipeline data flow
bigtable and the AI platform were all
part of that migration
you can also tell in the middle of the
screen we have a reverse ETL process our
user store in bigquery serves those
features into bigtable and then gets
scored or recommended through our
modeling scoring service all on gke
those recommendations get to our members
through our products 63 billion times in
predictions a day
and today we think there's even more
opportunity for future Innovation with
the possibility of spanner and vertex AI
using in our recommendation system oh
how are you using Google's data Cloud
today for your key use cases and what
are some business benefits you've
achieved by moving to Google Cloud one
we really focus on making our data
scientists as efficient as possible
and that meant simplifying access to our
users feature store as well as deploying
their models as quickly as possible
to give you some set of scale today we
deploy over 700 models a week as opposed
to pre-cloud it was almost 10 a quarter
additionally in experimentation we do
over 7x more experiments today than we
did before cloud
and with the help of bigtable and
bigquery we have 10x more features
deployed daily through our batch data
these gains can be attributed to what we
call our unified model training powered
by bigquery bigtable dataflow and
Google's AI platform
nice
what makes Ben repeating to you for your
operational workloads
we're considering span arrow for our
primary relational database to reduce
engineering toil Drive higher efficiency
and reliability to our core Mission
critical production database tier we're
a fast growing company needed to scale
and we think spanner provides some
interesting advantages in their
multi-region Global consistency and five
nines availability offering natively
through the products
this would be one of our most complex
migration processes moving live
production data into a new database tier
and so it will take a lot of engineering
effort we look forward to working with
the spanner product team on this
thank you so much for that conversation
Scott I really appreciate you joining us
today
thank you for having me Andy and I
enjoyed being part of Google next
as you can see from always spoken about
today the future of data has endless
possibilities
tune in to all our sessions and next for
more details on the announcements you
heard today
thank you enjoy the rest of next
[Music]